on national chess day October 12 2019
7:00 p.m. sharp we will be posting the
$1,000 national chess day intense just
Invitational featuring club manager
Jonathan shruts national master julienne
Pro Rico and all the other YouTube stars
and Pepe and national master Caleb
didn't bee will be doing the announcing
and they asked what the heck is intense
chest all right well it's a game like
you've never seen before it's game in
one minute with a 10 second delay it's
like a tennis match in chess and then
still illustrate it
I got 82 dollars cash to put up against
Tracy do you accept accept my guesses
game in 1 minute 10 second delay it's
touchmove it's intense
alright I beat you once I'll beat you
again
oh you make it too easy you make it too
easy this is not I didn't pay her $50 to
go into this so this is great this is
great this is my wheelhouse give er a
check
take the and now Yuri Schulman taught me
this back he's 53 naughty 2 D 3 where
you go oh you're attack up my night
you're attacking my night what's hacking
my night I don't not like that I thought
we made a pact like no discovered
attacks you know oh man
so if I go there you're gonna play there
if you go there you're gonna play there
oh my gosh
let's just go really really really
aggravate okay
are you trying to checkmate me I mean
discover mates checkmate
oh this is ways you're the first match
that's for sure
let's just get on with the show you know
if you want three for one okay one three
four - I knew you were gonna play there
I knew it just for the record let the
record show I get one of your guys here
and wonderful but yet queen of the
bishop one of them's got to go
oh my gosh
so I go there you go there then you go
there and then I go cry is that the deal
is that the deal
oh my gosh all cuz my producer Danny
would put film the thing right the first
five about $32 now thanks a lot buddy
thanks a whole heck of a lot alright a
little reprieve a little deep breathe
here it's intense chest I mean thinking
happen oh my god I can't beat you or cuz
I can't lose on this price before a tech
they aren't two nights the plants have
you left alright remove the defender say
goodbye to the defender oh and then
you're gonna play there but they're not
gonna play there and then you might
check made me anyway
Oh like
this is this is that I have to take I
have to take I have to take I have to
take oh you're so close
where are you so close so close let's
just get on with the show comer nope Oh
with this show checkmate me
Oh safe
all right here we go
I get a big check but I don't know if it
even does anything but it's checked so
check shucks
well that didn't do anything to anything
magnify my losing move no it wasn't it
wasn't okay okay
it's very very scary you're covered
enough okay I'm at eight seconds away
from losing 882 pucks
so this really doesn't look as
competitive as it was here we go master
tactics right here mastered tactics Wow
well there's nothing you can do anyway
so here's comes the master tactics
master tactics right all right as the
$82 secure now for real all right all
right everybody join us that's not just
the October 12th
Pepe Kaleb them be on the call it's
gonna be intense
welcome back to the Friday show I am
like Hummer how we playing the people
today right beside me is a Tony Chen
whose title I do not know it's okay
nobody knows at this point nobody knows
all I know is he's gonna be making the
Flyers all right the flyer guy and just
this week logged in the only person that
was challenging us HESA going away so
we're we playing all rated chest you can
challenge us three to 105 oh if you're
smart enough challenge us the intense
chess time control that's game in one
minute with a 10 second delay if you're
smart enough alright let's let's be
realistic how many people actually play
that time Marshall well zero cause
nobody knows about it but I know me and
Jonathan trance created it co-creators
of intense chess if you guys were
following if you guys were streaming
about since s since 3 we show the video
about intense chess that will be
happening tomorrow here the same with
chess club at 6:00 p.m. so follow us
then and you'll see all the players and
who wins it all yeah and they what a
what a thing they will win they will win
$500 for first place and then all the
losers can divide up the rest of the 500
that's right so it's gonna be a pretty
exciting show who do you think is gonna
do you have any any thoughts on who's
gonna win that one the favorite who's
the favorite on that national master
Julian Pro way - no master national what
is he like 28 250 23 now something like
that but he is most importantly he is
the world champion
oh what a check alright ladies and
gentlemen look at the chat on our stream
you will find a link to challenge
mic to a game on Leech s he has stated
anytime control you want well not and he
any bliss time control you want yeah
none of those none of yeah we saw
somebody who challenges to a three-day
game we're not doing that okay I only
have 90 minutes less than 90 minutes now
so only bliss time controls well
theoretically I'm not supposed to be on
the clock until 5:30 so I might play
forever okay that's cool so here's a
question for you Mike one of our viewers
asked does teamwork Richter Korea is
carica helping blindfold chess I guess
yeah that's a say more thing yeah I
guess if you if you feel good about your
haircut you you do better
agreed alright yep not the best not the
best ever
my first game first game lost 3-2 when I
was talking I like to play these people
why they don't know what they're reading
there we go who are you playing it's a
mystery no it's not game three never
belong to four name upon through 12 for
is he knew 1500 oh no what I know no
what do you know nobody knows nobody
knows so curious Mike which which do you
prefer
game 5 delay 0 were three three two game
game 5 oh just get it over with
none of this I can't agree with that I
agree with that if you guys want to
challenge him in intense chance time
control 1 minute delay 10 right yeah one
minute delay time yeah that would be
very funny yeah you can try it out see
see how you like it right I mean it's it
is intense because once you get under
that that 10 seconds and your real-time
starts running you know you don't know
what to do because you know you're
actually on the clock and it's kind of
cool that's where you you will see some
blunders tomorrow but you might see some
really good chests the first game will
be against two of the favorites in the
event adjourned Perea against club
manager Jonathan shruts so right off the
bat there's gonna be a huge game so
super exciting
I mean tomorrow is the start of our
chess
national chess day weekend all right we
have a lot of things going on tomorrow
actually so many how many tournaments
can we put in one day really we have we
have a Scholastic tournament off-site at
a at a middle school some and then we
have here at the Singlish s club we have
$1,000 in national chess a game 30
championship Europe that's gonna be
super exciting all right and then after
next so right after that tournament
well maybe during that tournament we
have intense chest starting at 6 p.m.
watch us for that as well that's gonna
be that's actually gonna be a pretty
exciting show so we have grandmaster
pepe cuenca doing commentary you know
how he is he's just like super fun and
flamboyant it's cool good to watch as
for the rest of the month next weekend
Saturday the 19th we have Saturday night
special right and then on Sunday we have
Sunday 6 player Swiss two tournaments
that have been going on regularly during
between a year but that's that usually
draws a lot of attention a lot of good
players it's a fun it's gonna be a fun
month actually all right yep and yeah
and then we'll have during that next
week and we'll have the the st. Louis
Master lab yeah it'll be off six player
five round-robin with all the with all
the up-and-coming stars of the Chess
Club well Mike J Patel would like to
tell you you rock well thank you thank
you thank you
and then always good for and this is a
gentleman named Lou key baby would like
to play you from Ireland it's not Luke
years no yeah well what try to what try
to remember your name we're not doing a
list today so Mike's gonna play whoever
he wants to and I'm gonna get checkmate
on the board
all right we got a channel just coming
in I know casual if you're good casual
you're out of here
oh yeah that is the one rule rated games
only like we talked about always we
don't do participation games here all
right
yeah yeah when were you you you win
points where you lose points right no
catch you're so gay
no casual this is the big leagues this
isn't just you know sit around just copy
yeah go big or go home
all right I've made um Blake I made the
man bling all right look or in this
position is horrible looky baby all
right you're Iran right now and looks
like uh Mike just mayonnaise you blink
I made you blink magic boy you must be
really bad at steering right yeah
killing already I killing you no it's
really you know it's really refreshing
that you don't set a parameter value
have to do this ty time delay to play
where you have to do something it's play
the people let the people decide it's
not my place three two you know love it
so for those of you who actually follow
Mike regularly you should know that he's
a big sports fan
they exploit oh yeah yeah that's right
we're in the red today yeah it was so
great the Cardinals decimated the the
Atlanta Braves by like 13 to 1 and we
scored 10 runs in the first inning
dominating and it wasn't even the first
time we scored 10 runs in a game we also
we were losing 7 nothing to the Reds
earlier this year and we scored a 10
spot on him to go up 10 7 capping off
with a 3-1 bomb from Jose Martinez right
see you've read maybe see you right yep
so it's yeah yeah Carnales they they
play get right back on it it's like no
no rest in the playoffs it's like let's
play let's play again
so yeah they won't be playing tonight at
7:08 first pitch yeah if you don't if
you
have a favorite baseball team follow the
Cardinals yep you're doing very good if
you do have a favorite baseball team
still follow the Cardinals there's a
good good team play you know that's how
it is here that's how it is that's how
it is
what about since I mean football season
s started up what are your thoughts on
that
what do you okay I have two teams this
year two tickets and they're both doing
great I have the four in Oh
San Francisco 49ers okay I've got them
to go to the Super Bowl
and I've also have the Baltimore Ravens
to go to the suit those were both
preseason pick so I'm not just like
latching on when oh oh these guys are
hot those are Mike teams now no I knew I
knew going into the season well
Baltimore Ravens okay The Rave it's a
demon the d love it
what's yeah what do you thought what are
you thoughts on Tom Brady so playing
still if he still upskill an acid
witnessing mad as well right
why give it up you know actually he says
it's even easier now even though he's
older but I mean he's got all the
experience and he could read defense is
so much better that yeah I mean he might
play another three three four years you
never know can I totally agree I mean
his is physically his body is not
wearing out it's still going there like
almost at his prime prime state so why
why give it up Larry and why give it up
it man that guy has a live to pro
baseball player pro pro football player
married - gizelle okay what else can you
say can you say blessed life who's your
who's your favorite cornerback is that
Tom Brady favor no Patrick mahomes no
favorite cause gotta be a Jimmy G from
San Francisco right that's my team I
gotta go with them
oh god never play up six but I'm tempted
I'm tempted were you were you ever a fan
of the rim Rams even when
they were here yeah of course I don't
never know some people was like I don't
like the ramps yes even less so now then
they moved so yes yes yes yes yeah yeah
do it got a big matchup this week out
San Francisco at at LA and I'm sorry to
say LA but anyway you know the Super
Bowl hangover it's a real thing Rams
obviously lost the Super Bowl scored
measly three points against good old New
England and you know there already have
two losses this year so I mean check
alright looks good out of the check so
how are you doing but against looky baby
here not too bad maybe I'll offer draw
see if he takes it yeah what are you
talking about why would you offer a draw
I would I offer joy cuz I'm gonna play
rook to be whatever and take his pawn
but maybe I'll get him
maybe I'll get him thinking now I
thought you were I thought your your way
of playing was this do or die why would
you it was because now I got him
thinking about the draw instead of the
game and anyway I was just checked you
know how devastating this to have you
have you never want Washington Mighty
Ducks movies series Gordon show boy or
whatever that the quote is you learn
more from losing than tying come on draw
oh and I got my beep on protective and
we have a couple of three bug free poet
alert free upon alert we have a couple
of people saying let's go Mike alright
thank you yeah one of them's a DTS
Chandra alright he's saying oh I'm in
check again am I gonna be checkmated
here let's just say no okay
and what was easy as young I said we're
not getting checkmate in a winner okay
Wow looking at you're used to dropping
pots like crazy why are you dropping
alright yeah it was all because of the
draw it was obviously draw offer a good
good strategy it good tactical move
right there offer a draw and then we're
gonna win let's see if I can convert
this work end game probably not that's
home
and he's a gamer rook endgame and just a
reminder to viewers there is a 30 second
gap between what we between what we see
what we talk about and what you see on
the screen so if there's any of that
lapses yes
is there any time elapses between what
you type and will we talk about
that's why Christopher Richter says
psychological warfare hey that's that's
hot top mic that does it that's how it
does he's got a pastor he's got a pastor
this gentleman says offer a job to make
him regret when he loses that's that's a
goal that's the goal here
oh okay
looks like your looks like I'm losing on
top there we go no no no I finally
figured it out
oh just watch this yeah oh then wark
never play hope so you made hopefully
just hope he wasn't come on come on
hope justice for though we yeah for all
you kids want watching this don't don't
play hope chest
the best move is to play the best move
and win Mike this gentleman would like
to play you his name Knight Rises
quantum chess I think I know who that is
I think I know who mr. quantum chess or
any of our viewers any of our viewers
are actually located in st. Louis be fun
fun to know if you are coming down and
play us in person oh okay okay
oh what a move what a move what a move
alright that was the move that won the
game for Michael Jake um ah nice nice I
like it yeah nice nice nice okay we'll
give you a hand for that one yeah
alright we got 14 challenges working
challenges let's see what this 0+3 is
all about zero plus three Wow
alright have fun with that one wow wow
they're starting in this game just to
give you some updates on what's coming
at the club in the next couple of months
if you guys are interested in watching
some high level players play we have our
2019 winter chess classic coming up
starting on November 9th
alright that's got it that's there's two
two groups of players and they're all
rated within with 24 to 2600 they're all
great yeah they're all great better than
look I'm just gonna say it better than
you guys so one of you guys when you go
ahead and watch us on stream if you want
to come come down and we'll see them
play in person you're welcome to do so
as well
all right after that immediately we have
st. Louis the fall Invitational which is
a norm tournament for all the for all
players that's trying to get a GM or I
am title that's what they're here to do
so if you want to watch that that should
be pretty great also and then let's not
forget grand chest or don't forget that
that's like the biggest yeah there's the
reason why I mentioned that last but you
always saved the best for last
Rancho oh right the best you want you
want to watch every leg of the grand
chest or alright and when is that
starting shouldn't pull this up what's
the first date on that speaking of which
have you been following um I I oh man
all the time I'll America who's in the
lead I'm cheering for Wesley and Fabi
the protest League champion all right
black resigned yeah yeah this little
nine-point nice try wasps nest nice try
remember you from the past couple of
times I've been on so let's see who else
is here
Adi I remember our - Nadia Levin yeah is
that is that good old is that good old
Adi
it's not it's not it's not it's not well
you're lucky yep challenge anyway audio
Levin how do you love me you're only to
talk on here I thought you were Harding
that what's that about
anyways drop-in nights are you sure this
isn't a real honey he's you're playing
like the repeat it could be it could be
I I could be completely wrong on that
one and Adi never never give a start
there's no trade that Adi doesn't like
regardless of if he's way they're losing
well so we got a couple more challenge
shock makan and wants to play too
after quantum chat if you want to st.
Louis too far how is uh I mean yeah st.
Louis to is far for some people but you
know plane tickets nowadays are pretty
cheap especially between during now
right October November is pretty cheap
there you go dude I remember I remember
back then back a couple years ago I
bought a round-trip tickets to China
from st. Louis and it was like 600 bucks
it was it was in it was end of October
so same time period I'm sure you know
everybody if you want to save us some
money and come here it'll be a fun time
it'll be a fun time yeah chess capital
of allure yeah why would if you're a
chess player why would you not want to
come here right you know like there are
grandmasters is wandering around all the
time
it's fun it's fun
[Music]
alright so sorry I went off topic here
so when with the grand chests or
November 6 you have the newly added
super bed wrapping the blitz
all right and then the very highly watch
tata steel tournament record of bliss
that's november 22nd so that's you know
highest the top players in the world
play play those so you want to watch
them right and of course long london
happens December 2nd and that should be
really fun so we're trying to break the
tie here one to one you play the black
piece another person would like to play
you his name is chess lunatic maybe I'll
play the low shuck makan you're up now
did you do you skip like what's this
name you sip quantum chess I think I
know who that
name them a call mouth is your name
Derek is your name Derek if it is we're
not playing you yeah there I play just
so many times in the and another chess
club not this jazz club before at the
old Crestwood Chess Club but now we'll
just say no one not that Derek okay well
if you say that we're not gonna trust
you your name is Derek now in the
regardless well magic year says this
game is a positional masterpiece look at
dark square domination from Mike some of
the last games oh yeah thank you for the
I'm sure Mike thinks he was like yeah
I'm good another person I wouldn't call
a masterpiece what would you call it
yeah what would you what would you wait
if you recall master and opus wait what
are you saying
look at that that master tactics right
there master tactics so this guy has
never gotten a chance to play you for
you for he would like to play you his
name is soo silly China okay all right
well since we got the connection
we'll do it okay you're in you're in
you all right next up is the silly man
yeah man those silly silly a lot is lost
I miss Chen so we hear a hey we might be
related you never know right oh oh
[Music]
Oh always I always forget about this
let's give a quick shout out to the man
in the back
Danny Machuca he he's just telling you
you can't hear him but he's like telling
me Jew jokes one off to your other and
it's kind of hilarious
Danny anytime you want to put on my mic
join us man join us I really stepped in
and they really are you losing to Chaka
Khan a badly oh you lost a nine huh yeah
I got too silly so much Chaka Khan you
got a chance bro
yeah you got a chance I got I got I got
I got some head on time that's what I
got going for me
let's see Kevin I am NOT from not
lunging I was born in the shy young
northeast been here since I was a kid so
I try to I try to go back every once in
a while but you know who has the time
right Chaka Khan you know what to do you
know one like once you have your hands
on somebody's throat just like right
yeah do the pincer movement and like
just get up
I watched ugh III hate I hate you know I
shouldn't even say I hate it cuz I might
isolate some fans but I don't hate that
UFC or you whatever it's called but I
used to watch and I was in Vegas for it
Kimbo Slice against the some old man Ken
Shamrock and Ken Shamrock was doing
everything right he had them all in this
this hold and three of the other events
are three of the other matches were like
once you got him in the hold the game
was over but then he let Kimbo Slice out
of the hole I guess what Keva slices and
knocked him into the into the cage yeah
that was it that was that like a
30-second flight for everyone who don't
know who Kimbo Slice is he's like this
big muscular guy like a hundred percent
muscle like you see him he's just like
muscle wants a like just coming up
everywhere so if you let him go yeah you
definitely just call the winners I know
Kevin was so mad because he was just in
this with chokehold and then he was
merciless unfortunately Kimbo Slice is
late Kimbo Slice yeah gitche good you
can challenge them to any bliss time
control you want 5-0 is fine are intense
core if nobody can figure out how to
challenge me challenge yet post 1 1
minute 10 second delay if you want to
challenge that try it try it yeah figure
it out I'm still ahead on time I'm only
down by two points I kind of like my
chances here I kind of still like my
chance and I think I'm gonna get a third
point on the board here and uh and our
good friend Danny much hook in the back
is putting out the link to Lee chest
where you can challenge us or challenge
Mike I'm not gonna play so click that
challenge it to a bliss time control and
we will get to you ok
you just move your rook okay it's not
rocket science there you all right this
gentleman from Brazil wants to play you
his name is dou dou T coughing phonos
maybe no guarantee no guarantees we try
our best
which by our best we got eight
challenges in the queue you so you did
not want my guy huh oh maybe because you
want my patient instead what I've done
we'll get a pass Pole one of our friends
says never play at five a five that's
not the rules that's silly
that's silly you just got made fun of by
Mike
that's silly yeah silly silly says never
play f6 but I played up six that one
game and I won something maybe I don't
even know what I'm talking about do I
get to I take a pass pawn
get a passed pawn wish you get a pass my
why wouldn't you all right let's get a
passed pawn another gentleman says
please play me I am at PA GB I don't
know where that is
no that's that's his name what the
headline in PG oh well well we'll get
you we'll try to get to you no promises
no problem we never make any promises
yeah whoa whoa he was really afraid of
that pass ball what's going on here yeah
because look at this master tactics
shotgun con man you're you're you're
going not starting to go down didn't I
tell you did I snow you even though I
was down by two I really liked my chance
and I really like you are just uh Wow
okay all right I guess I don't know if
it's a blonde there where if you just it
was up eating some dirty chicken you
can't concentrate like you know the the
ho
Leroy Jenkins thing if you wanted to be
if you're doing that you know we
understand food is a necessary part of
life
yep there it is oh so apparently this
was this guy apparently um this guy
who's won challenges everybody she lost
you
his name is silly China is he on there I
told you you were gonna get to play
silly China bro you have to challenge us
on Lee chess to a bliss hand control
otherwise we can't get to you mumumu
chess lunatic chess lewin Jack you're up
you're up buddy
so this sack I said he played he played
you before now he's gotten stronger and
once revenge even though Mike will
always be the hero of the people yeah
he's the people's champ why would you
yeah
2017 maybe the 2016 People's Champ you
never want to go against the people you
people will always boo you know if
you're not always pull yeah have you
guys never watching the boxing matches
with this is a mini Pacquiao People's
Champ like he might lose but people will
boo his opponent yeah I think maybe the
last time he played I was gonna bet on
that I was gonna bet on Pacquiao they
won on a split decision did you yeah I
watch that too and that was I was kind
of surprised I was like wow you kidding
me alright anyways Quandt quantum says
he says he's not Derek it's no play
you're not Derek alright well think
about it
we'll discuss it internally Kaiba
Kaiba too wants to play you please and
silly China says he he did challenge you
5-0 we didn't see your name is it
actually silly China where is it
oh there your control No so China radio
game man rated game we don't play casual
games yeah with the program we don't do
participation games hey none of that you
don't win you don't win points where you
lose points the games are just as good
as the hair Hey yeah is that your is
that your natural hair color my hair
color
yeah I've been fooling everybody for the
last 30 I decided I now that I'm in my
midlife crisis I might as well go back
to what got me there
all right so let's see Kaiba two wants
to play you quantum chess not Derek
wants to play you doctor
silly China rate a game radio game
alright and we'll pick you up is he in
there Oh sack man I know
no remit no reshot makan no more man
okay your head should say key geez geez
geez go let's go down let's go down
right there that guy China there we go
oh you don't want places Cecilia China
he's casual again casual games again are
you kidding me I'm not gonna lie to you
if you keep doing that we're gonna we're
gonna ban you alright alright I get why
he challenged my two unrated he's
intimidating player oh yeah you know how
like men use the word peacocking like
that hair
that's a P P cocking move to like you
know never you never heard the
peacocking Danny back me up on this have
you heard this
yes he yes yes Danny's Danny's hip he's
with it alright so silly tryna says
rated okay now he's on there and Kiki
still says channel gay I see
so Danny Machuca asked me if I know the
term peacocking from general just
general culture or the book the game
general culture I don't read so general
culture that makes two of us I don't
read either
oh my pinned oh all right so this guy
Sammy I saw Dee said it's 4:00 a.m.
where he's at right now and he would
love to finish his night with one quick
game against you guys bro challenge us
challenges well it sounds like a pretty
easy thing if it's for them yeah four in
the morning I mean it's I don't know I
don't know if you're your if you work
the nights or you're studying the entire
night or if you're just drinking you
know doesn't matter challenge us and
we'll might get to you might get to you
Mike's here is a mohawk designed for
speed all right yeah he's like he's like
the shark we're not gonna come land
shark because that is a trademark is not
a trademark name it's a it's a name of a
beer by anheuser-busch oh I I was gonna
say it's a nickname for Ray Lewis but
Ray Lewis yeah the light linebacker my
Baltimore yeah who calls him the shark
the land no Land Rover the Land Shark
cuz he's still capacity so this guy says
I challenge you to one one zero is that
okay it's your world
yeah man rule Barry your hair is very
aerodynamic very oh so you're a student
so you've been studying all night or
getting drunk so one of those two
all right challenged us to a game what's
your a leeches name let us know we might
get to you all right so this gentleman
says if I ever decide to pick up reading
the Wheel of Time series the epic
fantasy saga I highly recommend it I
will look into it if I ever decide to
read alright look into it
that's a snag good
are you losing - I camped in a tick I
can't figure it out I can't tell you
calm on the ropes
come on the ropes go go go go for the UH
what's this term called knockout okay
uppercut is that what is this guy go go
for it man you come on the ropes - keep
going keep swinging hey hey makers
haymakers oh now he's just getting
greedy these Japs you doing jobs right
now haymakers yes you don't want what
the ya-ya greedy he got greedy he got
too greedy he had it he should have just
taken my night when he had the chance
no I let me out he let me off the hook
it's not fair when you delegate that
bantering and blitzing over two people
what do you mean by that not fair
stopping you from doing this in your
house buddy I was about to say is it
yeah like is somebody is your room only
big enough like you not have two more
people there ya know and I'm willing to
bet that whoever's playing is not
talking to anybody so you know so if one
person plays and one person talks that's
perfectly normal perfectly normal
perfectly
are you still losing she losing
obviously come on man making us look bad
let's play over here see if this works
yeah let's see if that works Mumbai King
around like it like if you don't know
what to do is move your King around this
circle right like in real life you don't
know where to go just turn around the
circle's over and over again you find
out this guy asked who do you think will
win in the Isle of Man well Mike earlier
pointed out that he Fabio Rudy for
Fabiana and Wesley so yep you know - to
us us highly rated us players but more
importantly to champ world champions of
the 2019 protest that's right that's
right and we have big announcement we
got a third American
our team that's rated over 2,700 none
other than mr. linear Domingues hey if
you ever if you follow the chest we're
all linear domain guys did just switch
to the US Federation not long ago so
that's pretty exciting if you guys don't
know what Mike's talking about when he's
saying the protest League look yeah I
read it okay they they they just
published their new rules for the 2020
season yeah look it up look good look
this gentleman would like to ask you
what are your view on Michigan and it's
all right just yeah you know okay for
former world champion moment moto x
playing hi chess when is 440s just huh
yeah that's cool yeah that's cool yeah
so if this guy said a Italian and
Philippine to Philippine out well you're
referring to
Carano and so okay look up on the feed a
website man they play for the US now yep
right yep Bobby I was a real American
born in Florida Florida Florida you
can't get any more realer than that yeah
Wow three super GM's are IP opponents
yeah that's yes that's why we got three
true super GM so we can just uh
sometimes you might not even plate you
need to play all that well still gonna
win right how many years in a row have
you guys won the processing now we've
won it in uh oh that was bad move
Oh checkmate oh we missed it Oh do it do
it do it yeah come on come on come on
all right good result for that good job
woman take even though I was in a all
right
can't district disrespected yet non we
are not just expecting a nine at all we
have high respect for that guy that guy
said multiple world champions
championships who we play now you
playing uh-oh silly China where you what
are you okay horse helmet okay anon
multiple championships playing
high-level in his 40s that is that there
by itself is this just deserves respect
you know so this guy named while lead
three eight one three would like to play
oh one plus 1000 is this intense oh he
got intentional no but it's plus ten you
know what you know what I just I just
gonna resign alright so I know what I'll
play 1 plus we're not we're not playing
plug we're not playing plus 10 so if you
want to do that snap blips that's not a
blitz time control anyway no no not that
one you see let's try this guy I hope
and I can talk about what we really did
in the pro chess league we won the
inaugural championship in 2017 led by
Rose Lee so and then we went to San
Francisco without a super grandmaster
and ended up with the bronze and then
the following year we
we of course went back to San Francisco
beat Armenia beat baden-baden
to take two out of three and then we won
the summer series this year led by a
vorak ho bein with the in the regular
season and then we had the Nicholas
Theodore Wesley so far beyond Karianna
and Josh bloomer to win so so we are an
official dynasty of the protest we sorry
yeah what's going on here touch come
support Daniel support it it's so easy
watch this it's that easy huh look for
who we got to look for my cut my cousin
Shannon where are you at silly China we
don't see your name so I don't know
what's going on but we need to figure
that out before we can play you all
right let's meet this guy is it stark
yeah saying it o st Zurich Zurich is
that a play on the star Star Trek
character is that weird or is that just
someone walks father yeah
when I'm right here the worst sirak
ioniq think oh it's Fox dad I got that I
got to see the Wrath of Khan in the
movie theatre where uh Ryan Chester used
to work like wait how about the original
yeah they like they like I guess there
was like 25 30 years reunion as like did
get to see that it was it's kind of good
I never knew you were a Trekkie man are
are you do I just I just saw part the
fun of it no fun of it
Ricardo Montalban or whatever his name
is
it's a pretty good movie oh I don't say
about this this guy says Wesley so is
the original st. Louis Archbishop er he
took down Fabi when he was in he played
for chess bras yep we won in a double
overtime to toe eliminate in the final
four to eliminate those guys and it was
a good good thanks to our board for
Nicolas Rosenthal you know what you did
you did good kid yeah Rosie
Arya's danny wrench calls some rosin
salsa what so owner owner dove and lamb
just challenged you he wants to play
is that your Oh who's the 4:00 a.m. guy
I guess we did we miss him I mean let me
double check here the guy who says
student who was like 4:00 4:30 a.m.
right now who's what's your last name
let us know yeah yeah I'll try to get
you yeah we try to we want to get you in
because you know we always want to
support a current students in his life
so this guy said play me play me while
Lee Watson is that your Lita's name you
gotta let us know so we'll know who it
is alright so his pawn fork didn't work
in the game let's see if my pawn four
kids up working or maybe I just get
crushed with it so this is very weird
game to pawn forks by different players
but one work then let's see if this one
ends up working oh this guy's sucess
said it twice now so please play me I am
@p AGV so well yeah we're fun and watch
well underwater right yeah all right
compliments will always get you if you
guys ever want to let's see here let our
superior to know how good their job
we're doing please email info a sailor's
chest cop that work on our chat alright
and say some good work about us or write
a letter yeah you would do that yeah I
mean it is it is 2019 almost 2020 so
long email might be a bit better but we
always accept letters and the old school
is good old school is good while Lee
three eight one three chest name okay
well you want someone three and then oh
this guy said my username is psg s
soccer rook play me I will crush you Wow
Wow alright we'll see we'll see if we
get to you
see so far this stream Mike alienated
fans of fighting sports Star Trek fans
readers books but at least he didn't
alienate the people that's what it's all
about I saw that was the rabbinate I
didn't go there to spit this badmouth
Kirk alien anything is I don't get that
but that's cool you know what that's
alright that's alright alright I'm gonna
start putting names down saliva we
remember who these are
alright let's see who we got PA G be
right yeah pagp
you got almost silly shrine is there now
so they're on their play for him we're
where we promised well PA gbu raid at
five all right so you try now you're up
you're on we try to find your PA GB we
couldn't find you okay yeah
remember the child's to a raided game
bliss time control yes like China
doesn't know what he's got into he's in
the colored in court he's in the colored
in court
yeah you don't know what you're doing in
the Kellett in court
I bet Oh
Fabio I messed up fabien says play me
I'm famous which famous tank mr. famous
man over here mr. fake you tell us how
you're famous
maybe we'll get you on quicker are you
are you chest famous where are you like
you know other types of famous here oh I
lost my queen but I got a lot of
compensation for it not really though so
apparently the guy you're playing right
now is playing on his phone so he's
crushed oh wait oh you're you're talking
on the phone just let me say I don't
know what the deal you you're not you're
playing right now so let see how you do
all right whatever okay yeah whatever
quantum chess have you have you gotten
to play yet not Derek
have you gotten to play yet all right
one thing I got one guy playing I got
the gee-pole and I got the Jeep on oh
but he's going to he's targeting the
Jeep oh and another guy said I'm more
famous in my city than him then the
other night was that he was famous play
me okay we'll try to get to everybody so
here's a list of names that's said they
want to play you in case you wanted to
know I mean I see the list if you
challenge me that means you want to play
but but they want to be like I want next
yeah this is just whoever randomly you
know should I got your challenges often
that's why you got a tune in right at 3
o'clock amen this is my common rules my
common rules yeah you see that they're
doing the technology thing where like if
you go to a bar like the AI science guy
tells you who's like in first second
third fourth yeah like what a society
coming to if you need that if you need
that to get a drink man yeah man you
gotta grow grow with the times I can
vouch for that one guy totally famous he
is um I'm not gonna lie to you since we
don't know who you are you're vouching
for somebody else doesn't really you
know carry a lot of weight comeback kid
silly turn on looking back kid yes just
give it up and that's the second time
today I promoted and it was instantly
checkmate the comb stop sami el el sada
Sammy USADA what's your name again
what's your leeches name who wants to
play Wow chi Chi Bo wants to play that
might be evil Caleb though 5+2 where do
we go here all night he's we're not
playing 5+2
fine 500 is the max our let's play this
23 feel a little this is a guy that said
he is famous
oh he's famous oh good I knew it when I
saw about how about when we make a bet
if we win nobody know that never mind
never mind
I take that back he's two Cody's take
that back I'll pull my foot on my mouth
real quick real quick real silly China
says good game dude
yep yeah yeah yeah you played good kid
hip flick but I played a little bit
better
this guy's famous he's famous famous
oh so Sam 885 is the student where he's
like 5 5 a.m. right now so he wants to
play you before you fall asleep if you
could know any blitz time control any
bliss time control not just any time
control 3 2 is good 3 2 is good Kiki G's
play three two challenges all right here
we go here we go quantum chess aka not
Derek says one game please guys respect
how do you feel about bully you like to
play whatever every once in a while
PSG soccer Brooke wants to play you in
one one zero so I understand if they
challenge me they want to play me we got
it we got how they want they want to
they want to be pushed up in line that's
how they want to be Mike you are too
good unfortunately for you I'm I'm free
good Wow three good Wow it's very
impressive that is very impressive yep
yep I've got to say about that I'm
actually stunned by that what that
sentence the guy who was like 48 5 a.m.
right now says he just sent you a
challenge guard good I'll get you his
name is Sam Sam the mayor I am 85 we'll
get to you get to you it looks like Mike
the game again all right mr. famous mr.
famous yeah why don't you tweet about
that mr. famous are you gonna play the
student Sam something Sam 85
Sam 85 Sam number 85 I can see him I can
do it all right Sam 85 we don't see you
so we're gonna have to skip you unless
until you figure out what that is okay I
don't how to get to us oh look PS do you
saw soccer oh oh yeah that's the bullet
guy
that's the bullet guy huh I got slow it
down
monkey Oh Sam 85 telling me you do Sammy
you've been on the chat long enough to
know it is rated games only rating and
no participation games we don't do
casual all right you didn't win points
where you lose challenge again challenge
again why are you putting really quick
ones you know it's those trials all
right boy here we go
Lee Lee goat James all right all your
clock legs how you do
you're always declining my challenge so
mike has declined some challenges just
because one it's either a casual or the
time control is not what we wanted all
right so make sure it is within our
parameters please yeah yeah make sure
okay
while Lee three eight one three says
again please please play me palacios
please this guy says you're always
declining my challenge that's why
all right that's why make sure they're
within our parameters I think I know who
you're talking about I'm always gonna
decline that guy's challenges oh okay I
beat them once you had your chance and
you blew it
well there you have it you have one
chance in life and you blew it
right yeah had two yeah but you had to
do something and you reap what you sow
buddy yeah I I completely understand
where Mike's coming from because I don't
give second chances as as Danny Mahmood
chukka can can explain all right no
second chances here right isn't that
right Danny
you hold you shut your tongue right
there I have never given a second
chances it said Shawn declined Sam 85
your challenge was declined because it
was a casual game we needed rated rated
games okay
we don't play casual games here at all
all right right into the fork but it was
a trick it was a trick it was a true
Mike putting on to hurt let go James
looks like you're losing
Oh opinion to win it that's how we're
doing okay he's playing to first quick
hands quick hands quick hands it's gonna
be a draw is it yeah come on
oh it's a draw yeah drew the 2400 James
yeah good job good you managed to draw
an amateur great job great a good way to
make I love it let's go with the easy
guy just Kingdom well that boy you never
know you never know do you really that's
true you never know that's true you
never know we got some good games we had
some good I mean come on chess game
you're holding up the show here you're
gonna have to cut you off you don't make
other we go there we go did you just
even this is like assume that he was
gonna play ue4 I place c5 - no matter
what okay okay you can play any move you
want against me I'll play in c5 okay
it's the only move in the game you heard
it you know if you want to play you
figure out a win against cc5 you know so
cm 85 the student at 5 a.m. is
essentially new challenge
what yes he plays c5 no matter what
that's what I'm thinking my mind so dang
much you guys are commenting I'm like
even against d4 I pin the Caledon court
how many is one with the Caledon court
right Oh
b4 you sure sure CC 5 against p4 to Kiki
G says good game all right
apparently this guy who is not Derek
says plainy
name is Quan quantum just just if you
haven't got the picture yet get the pic
and he Jie said it's time to start with
B for now
Oh looks like somebody's on the ball
everybody's on the bowl and people was
following out a good idea keys so if he
was gonna start playing hey Laurie
you know Oh all right everybody played
before against Mike maybe I maybe I got
some maybe I got some moves maybe I got
some moves for that we'll see
we're actually everybody's curious I
hope if you're gonna do it everybody
starts playing before I don't I'm
curious I guess we'll just have to wait
and see well we just wait and see what's
happening come on come on oh that's
actually not even that good of a move he
just said you suck checking them yes
said you suck ass eesh Misha says accept
my challenge all right well if you
challenge us in a Raider game with bliss
time control we will we might get get to
you no promises no we we basically do
what we want we're outlaws that's us
are we on YouTube today or switch
YouTube YouTube oh right is that what
the National chest day things going to
be on tomorrow YouTube as well alright
so if you have an order you just turned
in we will have the $1,000 national
chest day intense chest invitational
tomorrow at 6 p.m. Central Time yes what
is intense chess okay oh man I might
lose X oh oh
so this gentleman is saying accepting
all challenges but one is just rude
you're playing against a lot of players
a lot of games that's not true we do not
play anybody are you me green yeah we
played me green remember I'm sure you do
I'm sure you do
alright so guess what you had your
chance your chance is over be cool man
yeah bro great be good we never actually
played more than play one player more
than once so that's kind of a rule
because we want to get many people
chances to play us PSG soccer brooke
says one-minute rated please play me
we actually saw saw your challenge
earlier
well it almost got me to play rook to
hear the which was which loses that rook
aah check that how you doing okay
oh all right well that's not
rook c8 followed by Bishop h6 woodwind
and the famous guy said rook c8 1 yeah
we're seeing of course rook CA 1 for the
guy everybody know because of Bishop h6
I just a even said it was a blunder
that's probably where you got the idea
oh sorry yeah I saw it I saw it the
whole time yeah you just got told by
Mike I'm curious do you have a nickname
that people call you my IQ obviously
well I I Q because my is so high IQ IQ
so it looks like we have a lot of
international followers here which is
great all over the world Europe South
America love it
China love it love it are you waiting uh
looks like he has a passed pawn over
there alright yeah but he's got the dumb
rook that when the rook is on the
queening square or the Queen e-file in
front of the public dome
look he called you dumb hey how'd you
DOM and he said he sucked earlier so
okay are you gonna take it you gonna
take that uh who John says hi Mike oh is
that a rexis mom that's cool
Fabienne says hello from France no it's
a wreck zoo yeah that's right
his last name is Xue zhe
yeah dad but so so that that's the name
from that's his mom's name if you say so
I'm trying to set up a big trap hi from
st. Louis do you could easily just come
to the club you don't even live that far
away come to the club it's a fine person
and shouldn't you be in school right
right now since you're musical right now
I think I'm losing he never fell for any
of us this is too much trash for chess
this bad and I tell you understand that
what's that referring if I take he takes
I go down there all right let's just
let's just pray that this works
it might work it might not work we'll
see flip a coin Manson it's gambling
time like gambling hung up guess what
it's blitz check yeah I guess amateurs
on the Internet
it ain't gonna be perfect all right dang
it I really wanted that polling oh
that's not good
let's just bluffing
I guess I forgot karma at the end of my
list of nicknames okay yeah well here's
a last name really a nickname maybe I
guess for some people I'm a few people
it could be but are are these seven easy
huh okay
if you play against someone one game on
onon others another stream he's not
allowed to send a challenge you got you
got it now now you're now you're
catching on now you're catching on
you you officially caught on officially
caught on all right now you can follow
us you're not behind anymore that's my
one chance is my one she can't you can't
be too greedy man
oh no oh crap oh wow
alright alright alright
chess King that maje good job good job
Chesky no no I walked white in the
checkmate but he didn't see I'll give
you a pre-emptive hand hands on that one
hand clap on that one good job good job
maybe yeah I guess you could
theoretically mess up good job good job
chess Kingdom we made fun of you a cup
cover times and you still won so props
props this guy says yeah Mike big brain
comer sounds better than what I tried
big so you you you you would prefer big
brain utter it rather than IQ I would
not yeah I would what that guy does I
feel like IQ is more you know to the
point yeah mate mainstream so much for a
big bring 200 IQ okay baby big brain 200
oh oh this guy said the for 1400 you
just play did I did what the 2400 could
not do day simultaneous time was saying
is he making fun of us and the 2400 I
love it love it cool so cool
we play in the the midnight man or
whatever the 4 a.m. guy dude that's not
him his name is Sam his name-o
hag B he's been in the chair yes yes so
yeah you guys you're you're up now so I
sent 5 minutes is that okay as long as
it's 5 minutes 0 zero delay or increment
that's fine rated only though rated
games only no casual night none of that
uh
I try my hardest so I should get a
participation trophy we don't do that no
we don't do that you win or you lose
yeah no shame in either one yeah but
it's better to win like many quotes from
many movies you get you learn more from
losing waiting and draw I don't I'd also
subscribe to any of that you just want
to win win win win win and never get
tired of winning ya ass call all our
protest League people that we left in
the dust what they learned you know why
it's dad that way because he's a winner
right he's a winner
always a winner in chess also sama-sama
is still here all right we're gonna try
to get to you get to you get you try to
get to your next man
yeah I thought win I thought we were
getting with you make sure make sure it
is a rated game make sure it's a blitz
on control make sure that you're still
in the queue when I'm done in this yeah
don't don't get out of there kind of
thing let's see here I just saw the st.
Louis Chess Club Lee chest profile and
there are a lot of games against the
same players that could be true within a
span of multiple days that guy again
yeah I could be true I guess we we do
when we do this show like you know
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday and Friday
they're a lot of the same people play us
on those days but not never really very
I really never seen anybody played twice
in the same same day against us
yep why don't we follow Christopher
Richter's advice and just chill all
right here we go sorry for the short
fella me I'm a bit sleepy I guess when
does this windows extreme ends so
technically it's supposed to end at 4:30
however mike has proclaimed that he
might just keep on going never end
we never know we never know I guess it's
all up to our producer Danny mature
because I'm not I'm we're ending at 4:30
okay you have 15 minutes guys - mr.
Bigelow this gentleman asks how about a
game of bullet challenges we might we
might get to you why not oh this guy
said I'm going to sleep soon guys good
stream though you Derek me so if you're
really not Derek we apologize we're
trying to get to you next time I have a
good night man the game we're talking
about was a few yeah I know exactly what
game we're talking about right you had
me you couldn't just beat me instead you
you know you give to me time and did all
this weird stuff and that was your
chance to beat me and now you know you
blew it okay yeah let's just call it
quits on that conversation right there
and move on
all right oh look at this look at this
uh astronomy says indeed I remember I
lost games more from tournaments once
again proof learning more from losing
alright this guy named beef Fisher would
like a game with you either way Thanks
we'll try we'll try it we're ending in
like 15 minutes so no guarantees play
bone bone uh trophy and lose rating
points really wow I like to I like the
confidence this gentleman would like to
ask you what's your favorite opening mic
aside from seats here aside from c5
that's all I play that's all thank you
c5 well well obviously it's it's that
color
variation of the Sicilian as 1998 July
chest life it's in there so I'm not just
making it all yep
dig around for your old mattress
magazines left like I did you find it
Karpov Zahn the cover today he this guy
says go but go up and oniy do you ever
play the Minami you don't just leave it
there how about you played it with me
all right
can i play can can you play me I am duro
ko will try to get to you 13 minutes
left so definitely no guarantees because
we got to play this guy Sam who is 5
a.m. where he's at and he's a student
trying to get asleep so we're trying to
get to him next and then we'll try it
for sure thought Fabien English only I
don't I don't I want to speak English in
Chinese so no no no French okay no
French props on me I'm trying to learn
no that's not not good enough the
lessons I got from my lost games are the
most valuable ones like everybody that's
that's how everybody is do you can check
I'm in check
now I'll put him in check see how he
likes it so maybe it's gonna be
checkmate this guy says I just
challenging you he you look like a
pineapple
haha hilarious
Sam you save our time damn oh my god
you're on place and who's the CEO we
gotta play cover time I mean how could
you not play cover I understand your
philosophy on this Sam I'm sorry man I
don't I don't know that I I don't I
can't control this
so we'll see what see what he does next
and will we get they want other
variation of the Sicilian we really want
to play again he wants to play against a
guy named comer time obviously you know
that's Touche Touche
how could you be named comer time and
not know the color variation this is the
actual color variation from the 1998
chess life I'm published I cut my own
opening comer time I thought you're
gonna play beat before man I think I
played before against this
maybe you're just resigned cuz right you
can't you can't beat you can't beat this
the you know the only opening guy look
at that it always took me two seconds to
make these moves is this three - it
should be just the Rio this is Rio okay
well then we have chances for other
people how many people in line we have
19 people in the queue right now and
we're just picking randomly I guess not
quite random comer time well we're
picking on bait based on who comer likes
to play more so Oh Mike is officially
out of control
Dave out of control Touche you speak
French not night I don't I know like two
words that's why I saw I saw where did I
see that I knew it was French but two
words you know so thank you for thinking
I actually speak more but I don't yeah
you're out of mine he is torturing me so
he can get a easy win Sam I I would
probably think that - all right well
we're definitely trying to get to
isn't that just drop drop drop a night
there it looks like it call my time you
are officially winning against coming
right now it's a good job good job
King be one a week is that
well I mean my one of my job's is to
kind of distract Mike so you guys gonna
have a better chance but he's losing
right now someone's gonna stay quiet a
little bit oh this guy's asked have you
guys ever tried atomic chess no
absolutely not
mm-hmm mm-hmm no no what kind of chess
will we play regular chess yeah or
intense intense chest tense sometimes
about bughouse I never really place
Sarah want chess I never got into that
but you know what else can you play me I
will play B for 100% of the time I have
yet to see one person play before right
now against this always survive
I mean people you guys been talking
about playing before a lot well like I
haven't seen anybody do it yet
because I'm curious of what he's gonna
play against before Danny Machuca and
the back Security's always he can play
against before so apparently this guy
who says he plays be 400% of time is an
amazing tactics master tactics master
that's what I was saying I'm the tactics
master from the stream today from the
big you can't you can't you steal my
nickname yeah how are you gonna how are
you gonna call yourself tactic tactics
master when you have them beat the
tactics man right that's what I was if
you ever want to beat magnus carlsen
learn how to play atomic chess he's only
like 94% I oh my percentile after 20
games though um nobody cares about
atomic yeah 1 there's a couple things I
wanna say one really nobody cares about
how much s that's no offense to you I'm
just saying like how many people
actually play that right and 294
percentile is probably high I mean he's
magnus carlsen so it doesn't matter like
he's gonna he's gonna beat every one of
us alright but thanks for the thanks for
the advice though yeah
oh so this guy who says he's gonna play
B 407 times says he he he prepared it
for four hours do you believe that no
because it's like did you actually
prepare all day long today so you can
actually play his mic cuz you knew he's
gonna play c5 I don't believe it
there will be no trade
kamar time you are a Fisher oh you're
you're doing good you're doing good
little red he's in the red 19 you got to
move quick man
quick hands uber micro uber micro does
anybody know what that term means this
did this hand gesture and uber micro
anybody know what that means
anybody if you if you do well then
you're as old as me if you don't I mean
it is pretty old so no no no hate there
comer time Hey
comer time you lost your advantaged is
that just because time times trouble
what's going on
come on oh I just dropped my guy I'm so
bad at chess I have just literally
batted how more time you you had it you
had a chance there but you lost it had a
chance to get that rook man but you're
definitely not gonna win oh wow okay oh
come on man Mike is mice droppings
pieces covers dropping Pearson you're a
comer time this is kind of hard to say
when his name is comer and you're comer
time Mike is uh basically as gaming up
now cuz he's dropping pieces everywhere
draaga uses everywhere you're thinking
about jazz hands cool cool
I become ur time come at I'm good
alright that's the end of the stream but
yeah five minutes left five minutes
play play against the kid Sam he in poor
kid he's been waiting for it like an
hour for you to play him Sam you're up
all right gotta beat you in five minutes
so this is the last game so that
everybody who's wait waiting you guys
who just can't split your games right
now because this is the last game all
right
we're only play against Sam cuz he's
been waiting for a long time it's like
5:00 a.m. where he's at
dude and yeah he's going to school
tomorrow well not tomorrow but he's
going to school so we're trying to
trying to educate the student educate
him like educate him come a variation
all right
[Music]
you know about this trick if you didn't
want to move your queen just take his
king you know and that's an illegal move
obviously so you can't do any mouseland
yes
yes it's a good trip it's kind of a kind
of learning from Danish dude I mean if
you guys were watching this stream how
do you guys not know what to do against
I feel like he's gonna fork you it's
alright I got some I got some
all right that's that's not good then
it's fine what look at this look at this
okay okay I like it I couldn't I better
like I feel like he's gonna take you
good now what you've got now what you've
got in that night strapped b6 bishop
there bishop takes a crushing this kid
Sam he's crushing you okay bro she's
pushing you oh there goes your +3
advantage what's your name and rating on
the right
Oh me my name is Tony Chen Lu like I am
commentator extraordinaire amateur
breakdancer theoretical vegetarian
what's my rate rating I think my actual
rating is like 1200 so that's why I
don't play but thanks for thanks for
asking though appreciate it
this is all part of the variation is
this part of your variation obviously
I'm a little book look at that it will
only took me 40 seconds to do this
alright what's going on he's 185 you're
gonna pull up man you're you're it's
like it's like you're flying and playing
in your doing you know nosed I pull up
oh I love giving them checks look at all
these checks I'm giving them Oh with the
the F point is protect yeah I like the
pin though I'm like the pen like the pen
oh I should have checked them on b5
let's do that all over again
hey don't make fun of me for being a
theoretical vegetarian I try to be how
healthy you know sometimes just uh as a
human being you get urges so sometimes
it doesn't happen you know 1200 GM
that's what they call me good good job
pointing out that's actually what they
call me do you guys does anybody know
who who can watch this he'll be playing
in the thousand out against the mystery
man who could the mystery man be so Ken
West is the GM according to US only
but you know that's uh that's when
people call me edgy I'm like yes I am
yes I am can I prove it no but you know
keep calling me that
spray it around like wildfire
you oh I I look like I should be a GM of
course of course
why we look the part you look at the
part that's all that matters in life
perception it doesn't matter if you can
actually do it or Sam you're uh you're
not doing too good man
Sam you're nothing you're good you're
negative - yeah you got a you got to get
in the get back in the game get back in
the game you know it's like if you're if
you're drowning in water you got a
paddle you know do one of these like oh
yeah do do something do something
because if you don't all that's gonna
happen is after this game we're gonna
give you a hand you're gonna go to sleep
mad so you might try to win try to win
nobody should go to sleep mad that's a
good advice for all couples everywhere
all right don't go see mad cuz it only
brew brewing on the inside
comer time was a fish ah well yeah I
mean that that's he got the yell you got
it yeah he got us he wanted to he got us
to play
being a vegetarian is good for the world
but for your health it's best to just
eat a variety of foods that's that's
actually might be one things however
I've talked a lot of vegetarians and
vegans and they have a different
perception so I I agree with you I agree
with you all right okay
oh okay everybody that guys at GM okay
yes I am thank you
all right tune in tomorrow the thousand
dollar national chest day intense juice
Invitational 6:00 p.m. Central Time
thousand bucks up for grabs
national chest day game at 1 minute 10
second delay Pepe and Kaleb on the call
I'll be doing the interviews over in
Studio A it's gonna be a great time to
it good night
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club